inauguration day in the tension and antagonisms
of the moment the defeated president and the
president to be barely speak as they ride
together to the capital for the swearing-in
ceremony the day is overcast and sullen shadowed
by uncertainty in Washington and throughout the
land for America something is ending this day
something is beginning and no man can tell what
one thing only a certain on this 4th of March
1933 the old order changes yielding place to new
from the 32nd president of the United States in
his inaugural address come words that electrify
a people desperate for hope and assurance this
great nation will endure as it has endured will
revive and will prosper so first of all let me
assert my firm belief that the only thing we
have to fear is fear itself whatever may be said
of him this the people sense he is not afraid
that night the new president promptly breaks with
tradition he does not attend the inaugural ball
instead he launches immediately on a program
of legislation and reform without precedent
in American history the New Deal begins at once
this nation he has said asks for action ends next
day Sunday with secretary of the Treasury
wooden the president orders every banker
the holiday begins to side chat
let me make it clear that the
banks will take care of all needs
and it is my belief that hoarding
during the past week has become an
exceedingly unfashionable pastime